time the democratic vice presidential  nominee was in town today  kamala harris was here to help motivate  voters to take part in early voting  you've been organizing you've been  registering people to vote before now  you've been reminding people about early  voting which  is over on friday october 30th  you've been telling people about what's  at stake  you all have been as you always are  leaders and fighters for the best of who  we can be as a country and i am just  here to thank you  i am here to thank you nevada  senator harris stopped earlier in the  day in reno before coming here to  southern nevada  this was the second time that the  senator has been in las vegas just this  month